hey what's up guys welcome back to my
channel in this video i'm going to be
interviewing a couple of property
millionaires and they're going to be
explaining how they've built up their
portfolio and become financially
independent one of their properties
alone that they secured on a lease
option agreement is bringing in over a
hundred thousand pounds a year their
deals are crazy and they're going to be
sharing absolutely everything how
they've done it how you can do the same
thing too so if you enjoy my youtube
channel please do me a massive favor
smash the like button and let's get
right into this so firstly mark and
martin thank you so much for coming down
to my house thanks for joining us so i
remember when we first met you actually
came down to my other house down the
road and uh this was maybe a year or so
back now a year and a half ago and you
were working on this juicy lease option
agreement deal and you know since then
you've gone on to do lots and lots of
deals you've built up a really big
portfolio so why don't you just firstly
before we get into all the deals and
what you've done give us a little bit of
background as to who you are and why you
decided to get into property in the
first place so um started approximately
12 years ago
did a hmo
which was a brr and went in did all the
work ourselves and then slowly being
working our way through and getting
bigger and bigger hmos as time's gone on
and um yeah it's been it's been good but
it's been just the two of us um we've
been doing everything ourselves and then
all of a sudden we've um obviously
during lockdown and bits like that and
with kids been watching a load of
youtube videos uh came on your course
and uh yeah i've been done smashing it
for the last year absolutely and what
you've done in the last year is more
than most people would do in a lifetime
so um and occupation-wise you're working
as a carpenter and yourself i'm into
sales car sales right and now you're
both going you've scaled back a little
bit on the on the day job what's the
reason for doing this like what what
what what's the motivation for wanting
to build up this big portfolio um i
think it's like with most people it's
just money initially
financial freedom just knowing that if
anything happens obviously when we
started no one ever thought kopi would
ever exist
um and then as time's gone on our plan
has changed we've both got young
children and it's just being having more
time we now value time over money yeah
it's been our spending time with the
kids and family and just enjoying life
um but part of that is not having to
worry about money yes freedom yeah so
the freedom to do what we want really
you guys are brothers
did you decide that you were going to
build this together or how did that how
did that come about yeah we just
started doing it together and just uh
obviously it's good doing it with
someone else but doing with your brother
it's probably even better i think well i
work with my brother as well so i
understand that um so okay i wanted to
firstly talk about this deal this lease
option deal because this is just a crazy
deal um firstly why don't you just
explain what is a lease option agreement
and how did you even
know
like what a lease option was and talk to
me a little bit about that
youtube watch a load of videos i've read
a lot of books um and bits like that
with regards to learning what a lease
option is so basically a lease option is
where you control the building
um normally with a very small deposit
normally hopefully a pound
you then control that building for x
amount of time generally approximately
five years sometimes longer sometimes
shorter with the option but not the
obligation to purchase it at the end of
the agreement so it's a little bit like
buy now pay later a bit like when you
buy it when you buy a car and you sort
of put down a small deposit and then you
pay a monthly fee and at the end you can
choose if you want to buy it or not a
little bit like that but for houses
which means that you can start taking on
much bigger projects than you would
if you you know because obviously unless
you've got loads and loads of money
so okay
you've now got lots of different
development deals or all going on and
you're using this option strategy but
that first option that you did which is
what we spoke about in the early days
which we were in negotiations at the
time and i think i remember when you're
in the house i was like
where are you up to it and you sort of
shared it with me you knew it was going
to happen you had a complete faith but
you hadn't got any contracts you hadn't
got the remembrance of understanding
signs um now it's generating a hundred
thousand pounds a year and just over and
um
talk to me talk me through the figures
talk me through the negotiation and then
we'll go on some of the other properties
initially we're going to try and buy it
just as a normal commercial building and
the valuer came out and down valued the
property so we were like all right we're
trying to work out ways around it so
instead of just going oh no walking away
we then thought well what's the solution
for this all right let's go down the
route of a plo
the seller was happy so actually that's
how we got onto the plo just thinking of
alternative ways of purchasing how did
you pitch it to the seller why would
they
why would the seller accept a payment
later rather than just getting a
straight sale so she's got a couple of
hotels in torquay and
she just wanted to kind of get rid of a
couple um and just focus on one um so
yeah it worked for her yeah i think she
was struggling to sell it so obviously
she's not desperate to get rid of it but
if she's struggling to sell it we
definitely wanted to build in we knew
you could make some good money out of it
so together plo worked
it's weird at the moment all the hotels
and torquay are getting soaked up i
couldn't believe they go back 18 months
and there's a few on the market well
yeah it's and it's funny because a year
and a half ago or two years ago when
everyone was being all fearful and
saying sort of like what's gonna happen
with the market let's wait and see and
you know me you you're watching my
videos i was saying get in now the
problem now's the time right now's the
time and it's gonna boom um and the
newspapers are all saying property
prices are gonna crash that's what they
were saying i wasn't saying that i was
saying no they're gonna go up get in get
in get in we met you came around my
house and since then we've done a lot
together but um so you secured this um
hotel on an option what have you done
with it since well we did want to turn
into um hmo basically because it's 13
bedrooms all of on suites been in a
perfect hmo so um we tried to get
planned for that which we couldn't get
and then the council actually contacted
us and said we'll turn it into a hmo
then the council themselves couldn't
actually get planned for either
so then we uh fork we do with it so we
turned it into essays
and in the end it's a blessing disguise
for making more money out of it now than
we would have done if it was a hmo so
talk to me about that so you wanted to
run it as a hmo but you couldn't get
planning
which you thinking oh no what am i going
to do but then this is the way the
toolbox comes in man yeah
if you only have one strategy or two
strategies you need to understand all
the different strategies you you
understood service accommodation as a
strategy tell me what does service
accommodation mean you'd um have a
building or a flat and you basically
rent
the flat out on airbnb booking.com and
you do it on a day-by-day basis rather
than long-term asts okay
and how much profit or is this
generating this property just over 9 000
a month so 109
incredible yeah incredible and what did
you think what did you think when you
saw the bookings coming in and the money
coming in how did you feel well it was
good it was good it was good feeling
it's just nice to see and especially the
first all that hard work and you just
see the first few bookings coming in and
then they just literally just kept
coming and kept coming yeah that didn't
alone a lot of people would just retire
off of that deal you know so you you're
presumably saving up the money ready to
buy the property yeah so no we'll get a
commercial uh mortgage on the property
um pull all the money out and that we
invested plus probably another hundred
thousand pounds yeah 110 i believe um so
yeah not only is it um very little money
in but we'll actually
um cash flow 109 and it will also give
us just over a hundred thousand pound as
well nice
a lot of people think that uh successful
people if you land a deal like that oh
just luck you got lucky but you've since
then you've gone on and done lots and
lots and lots of properties you've
secured a whole portfolio of hmos the
portfolio now is in the millions which
is which is incredible um what other
deals have you got going on what are the
more recent deals that you've been
working on we just got accepted
yesterday on a um
[Music]
three bed semi-detached house which
you're gonna do
split the deeds turn into three separate
flats
which has already been three separate
flats for over 10 years and what's the
figures what was the uh purchase price
agreed the purchase price
um it was up for 250. we got it for 215.
215. how do you get a deal like that in
these times these booming times where
everyone's trying to 250 to 215
and they said yes is this on the market
off the market it is on the market on
the market yeah so why did what why did
they accept your cheeky offer
because it's when you actually look at
actually it says a free bed house it
doesn't actually look that good when you
actually look at the details of it it's
actually free flats
so a lot of people wouldn't actually
look at that because yeah because we've
looked into it so this is the point then
rather than looking at the property and
seeing what it is you've got to be
educated and look at what it will be
yeah and then you might pay you know
a price which most people would think oh
that doesn't that doesn't seem uh cheap
but you know what it's going to be so
you're going to turn into three flats of
what that cost to do that probably
around 30 000 to do renovations there's
gonna be light renovations gonna change
the kitchens change the bathroom yeah so
you're still under 250 yeah even after
your renovation and then what's the end
value going to be on that approximately
just over 350 so we'll pull out about
just over 100 000 pound profit
incredible incredible well
congratulations on that what and what
else have you got going on i know you've
got loads going on you've got a whole
list on your website of all your houses
and your dresses and everything anyone
that's a a doubter i'll put a link in
the description can look and see all the
houses all the addresses which is crazy
what's the focus now land development
mainly um big
commercial um to residential or big um
conversions is what we're after
basically we're just scaling up and
going bigger and bigger um as time's
gone it's just natural progression for
us yeah so we've currently uh secured a
grade two listed building which we're
getting subject to planning to convert
into nine flats
um which is awesome i've got another plo
for a commercial building to turn that
into six bed hmo it's a bit smaller than
we generally want but um so we've got
that in the we're just waiting for them
to come back and say yeah but
by the sounds of things everything's a
goa yeah um we've got a big seven figure
profit uh one in the pipeline um that
somebody came to us with
amazing so you've got so many deals and
these deals we're not talking about
making five in japan a month here five
in japan a month there you're talking
about million pound profit in some of
these deals
what would you say to someone
that was starting out because you know i
mean
it wasn't that long ago when you were
just
small-time investors with a few little
buy-to-lets now working on these huge
deals what would you say to someone
starting out that wants to get into the
bigger deals development um what advice
would you give them once get started
training
you you need to know all the different
avenues that you can go down the route
of
and in this sort of business you will
find out there's roadblocks and it's
just different routes to get to the end
destination
um so going down and just going oh no
that doesn't work well actually if you
go down that road might actually be
better um it might actually be able to
make a better profit yeah it's just
different solutions um and also because
you're dealing with a lot bigger monies
um you don't want to mess it up were you
reluctant to spend i don't know how much
do you guys invest in the education even
with us a thousand pounds on it for the
for that development mastermind
in total in education so far yeah and
was that something that you had to
um you know was that painful or did you
just think it's just obvious that we
need to do it it's it's strange because
when you you yeah you're
paying the money over you just like
that's a lot of money but when you're on
the course and you're doing it and after
the course you're like why is it so
cheap yeah it's it's strange how you
your mentality changes as soon as the
course um progresses yeah yeah
development mastermind course if it's
like ten thousand pounds seems like it's
a lot of money
then if you do one deal when you make a
hundred thousand pound out of it that's
ten percent of your first deal do you
mean one deal that you could do yeah you
could do lots of deals you mean it's
nothing but to begin with and again what
you did which i think is a good thing
is you know i mean you watching me on
youtube for ages you must have spent
hours and hours watching the youtube
videos first yeah my kids are the same
age as yours you know when you're doing
the night feeds and it's just yeah i've
just watched hours and hours and hours
of uh yeah videos yeah and it's just
yeah but that's that that's a really
good way to get started but then if you
when you want to start actually
investing big sums of money into
property invest in a little bit in
yourself first just to get that because
you you know you guys if you ever have a
deal you can pick up the phone you can
speak to myself the team russell ben
bounce deals off them and you know you
might miss something even when i'm
buying the deal i've got i'll pick up
the phone and i'll ring ben and russell
and the guys because everyone has blind
spots you might not realize oh actually
there's there's this issue or the road
isn't the access point isn't quite wide
enough or there's flood risk or there
can be so many different things that you
can miss and having i think just having
a group of people around you consultants
and mentors um i think is a you're
either going to pay for your education
or you're going to pay for your mistakes
ultimately yeah definitely what's it
been like over the last year or so then
on the uh on the mastermind what sort of
happened yeah it's been awesome to well
it's just been so good just obviously
the training to start with and then just
being around the same people as
yourselves who are looking to do exactly
the same stuff and then obviously you
keep in contact with them and then
you're sort of dead doing some deals
we're doing some deals it's just nice to
see what's going on around us as well
it's good yeah it is it's just the whole
ethos of everybody the trainers
the other students on the course
everyone just kind of
brings everybody up
just it just motivates motivate
motivation yeah yeah and when i shout
out to russell and ben as well because i
know that they're you know very involved
with the hands-on sort of mentoring and
stuff um so okay so moving forward then
you've got these land deals and stuff i
want to ask how are you finding deals
because that's one of the biggest
questions i get at the moment people are
saying where are the deals i'm going
into agents i can't find anything where
are you finding these deals and how do
you know whether a deal is good or not
how do you go about appraising sites and
because because you know you just bought
a deal recently for 215
presumably if it was if that was on the
market other people have passed on that
deal so how do you spot a good deal and
where are you finding these
opportunities from so with regards to
um we'll have a look at white move like
everybody else uh word of mouth i
actually was um on the telephone i was
just helping out i don't know how he got
my details but um
ross uh phoned me up and said oh can you
just help me with this um he was looking
at purchasing a hotel um in torquay as
well so i was just giving him some
advice
and
like i wasn't trying to jump on the deal
or anything i was just helping him out
um happened to be that it didn't go
through for him uh sadly and that's
about six months ago um
last week he then contacted me and
that's where the seven figure profit one
came and goes i've got this do you want
to jump on and you want to help us out
okay so that's like a joint venture yeah
interesting interesting so how many of
your deals would you say are
from joint ventures or from deals coming
to you from within the network versus
you going out and actively picking up
the phone ringing agents to be fair very
few and we've been very um we're not we
don't brand ourselves we've only just
started branding ourselves we've been
very quiet about what we do and what
we've done um
of course there's quite a few friends i
actually don't know we're in property at
all crazy that is yeah
um so yeah we don't go shouting which is
something that we're going to start
doing and moving forward
because moving forward now um the thing
that's been holding us back is cash flow
or fraser our own cash because we've
only used our own cash to build our
property business and the whole idea is
to build with joint venture people
so we can scale our business and make
both ourselves and the joint ventures
obviously uh a ton of money is the idea
yeah but yeah and that's the way forward
yeah because i i guess if you've owned
if you've got a pot of money even if
it's a million pounds if you're having
to use your own money for your deals
then if you invest into a deal you've
got to wait for that deal to be finished
which could be a year two years or three
years before you can pull it out which
means that you're only working on one
day at a time whereas if you are using
other people's money you can then do
five ten fifteen deals all in one go and
and ultimately make a lot more money and
also help other people do the same thing
yeah so with the last two that we've got
in the last four weeks they've both been
uh joint venture deals um so yeah you
you won't make all the profit but
50 of profit is better than zero what's
the plan then is it to set is it to
develop and sell or is it to develop and
refinancing yeah just just develop and
so on and get the profit and then
hopefully get a few few more projects on
the go and just sort of keep recycling
it bigger and bigger yeah the game plan
for this year is to get 10 development
deals hopefully some land deals were
actually building houses on them yeah so
on nimbus a lot sending out letters
and um picking up telephone speaking to
a lot of state agents trying to get
um
any bits of land before it actually hits
the open market rather than waiting for
it to be on trying to find investors as
well trying to get as many jv
partners as we can trying to get
investors it's nice to have some good
relationships
well you know me even myself i invest in
a lot of my students deals and being
part of a community if you're trying to
do something on your own and no one
knows what you're doing and you're doing
it in secret then no one can help you
this is what we've found well after
doing the course and bits like that it's
just like yeah i wish i knew
now
10 years ago yeah yeah so what are you
most excited about at the moment
um
finding some more land kind of some more
land getting some more developments on
the go obviously we've got two two on
the go now we just want to try and get
as many as we can ready
what do you what do you think is um
better to start with if you're starting
out to try and be doing land development
or to start with doing small buy-to-let
htmls if you're starting again small
work your way up we're quite fortunate
that we've now we've done all the small
stuff we've got a nice cash flow coming
in um so we've got a backup so as and
when um everything then goes all right
it's now gone crazy we've just got three
deals landed on our lap last week we now
need to spend time on them um if needs
be we can just quit normal work um and
focus on that yeah but it just gives you
that security and
stuff like that so as and when you want
to then jump onto the bigger stuff you
can do so and it's just the knowledge
it's just a natural progression
yeah what would if you were advising
yourself from say two years ago when you
were just sort of getting started on the
development side of things um what
advice would you give yourself from two
years ago so it'll probably be to
um once again just do the training yeah
droning and it's quite literally it's
one of those things it's just hands-on
if you don't get
in the thick of it you're never gonna
know so it's just action action action
picking up your phone trying to find
some land driving around
um
get on nimbus get looking for some land
yeah the amount of like land sites that
we've been to view yeah like
going through like
um fields and like fruit bushes and
stuff like that yeah yeah and it's
amazing as well about that how many
opportunities are on the market or being
sold
that are terrible and shocking like this
and we spoke about this at the
development deep dive where i think i
showed some examples at the time where
some um the establishers had put all the
computer generated images yeah and and
and sold something and just i'll subject
to planning but it's like there's no way
you're gonna get planned and there's
green belt it's in flood risk there's
protected trees on the site there's no
access
it's right next to a railway and it's
just like are you kidding and then
muppets come along and go oh well well
let's take a punch yeah the amount of
stuff i look at now and then if before
i've done the training i've looked at it
and then oh my god it's a great deal i'd
have been doing those due diligence
wasting loads of time on it
and then now as soon as i see it i think
it was a good deal and then because i
know because of the training i know it's
not a good deal so just
yeah yeah and you need to because
because you can and i have to say this
um on the interview
with development especially
you can lose a lot of money yeah yeah if
you don't know what you're doing if you
know what you're doing then you can even
buy on an option the reason you buy an
option is because
you don't risk
yeah exactly it mitigates the risk if
you just buy it cash which you can do
and we've done that we've bought land
cash and sometimes then we're a bit
sweating yeah because if you don't get
the plan
it's an expensive field right whereas if
you get an option on it get an option on
something and then if you don't get the
plan in walk away and just lose a few
thousand pounds if you get the plan in
bang
ka-ching yeah that's where the money is
right but people don't know this
people think that you just have to buy
it cash but it's ridiculous
and not many people are doing this not
many people are in this space and i
would personally suggest anyone that's
wanting to start making a million pounds
here in a million development start
you're going to mess up on your first
few deals right at least mess up on
small deals
if you want to understand how an auction
works
don't go and bid on on on on a massive
piece of land for an auction with a
thing crossing your fingers that you're
going to get planned to build
go and buy a 30 grand house for a laugh
go down to some auctions and keep your
hands in your pockets and just watch and
see and learn how it goes before you
actually start putting a lot of money on
the line
um so okay so moving forward then
development lands making loads of money
when will enough be enough
we're very driven people so i don't
think i don't we haven't really got an
end goal we just sort of when you're
networking when your network is bigger
than samuel leeds then enough is enough
do you remember when i showed you that
once at the castle
remember when i had a go at yeah telling
him he's old i didn't think you joined
the mastermind after after after i did
after i said that but you did yeah yeah
you could
get on it i was like oh yeah all right
no because the thing is sometimes like
when i'm training i have to remember
that my job isn't to be liked my job is
for people to get results
you know and and um you know i think one
of the things that i pride myself on as
a trainer is my students get results
like there's no other trainer on the
planet certainly in the uk that's got
the success students that we get through
the training what do you think that is
just uh i just find it very very
motivated and
we've done training before in like a
classroom environment i just struggle i
just switch off and i'm not very good in
that situation but with your training i
just felt like i was just in the room
all the time it was just so easy just to
soak up the information
just found it really good well i'm
really pleased what you've done and it's
really i'm really honored to have been a
part a part in your journeys so massive
respect i'm going to put a link to your
website in the description if you want
to look at the houses that you've got
going or want to connect or do deals
but before we we wrap up what will be
your final words of of wisdom um connect
with people we found that
the bigger would get the
less it is about the property it's more
about the network around you yeah 100
percent so with regards to we're now
heavily focusing on uh jv's um so we can
build um our property portfolio we've
got a good power team but it's just the
team and the connections you have like
that seven figure deal coming to us and
things like that it's a people it's a
people business obviously you guys
training us and stuff like that and the
support um that you give us it's it's
brilliant yeah i appreciate that um and
i tell you what as well for me one of
the reasons that we do train is to meet
good people and it's just been a real
honor getting to know you guys and
hopefully we'll do joint ventures
together in the future so martin mark
appreciate you coming down to my house
and sharing the story all the way from
devon yeah it's a real honor and guys
i'm sure you agreed that that was a
really really insightful interview so
why don't you go ahead and smash the
like button if you want to check out
their their journeys their stories and
connect there's a link in the
description also if you want to come on
down to the development training that we
do we have a program called the
development secrets intensive and i
don't very often do development training
but i am going to be running the
development secret intensive very very
soon there's a link again in the
description you can check it out it is
free it's free to come along but the
catch is there's limited spaces
available so get booked on that right
now if you want to see more interviews
like this you can check out an entire
playlist i've been doing this every week
interviews like this for the last three
years don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and we will see you next time
[Music]